delicious saffron flatbread with mussels
it doesn't get any healthier than that
first job the super easy saffron
flatbread
put the saffron
into the bowl
and a couple of teaspoons of hot water
that starts to infuse
the saffron
and so you can maximize on the color
across your flatbeds
to make the dough simply add plain flour
a pinch of salt and pepper to a bowl and
then pour in a dash of olive oil
that makes the dough nice and silky and
rich your saffron water you'll see how
concentrate it is now
and you'll need cold water
then simply need to bring the dough
together mop up
all your flour
you can see now
the saffron's activated it's got that
really nice color
beautiful
use your wrist
and just knead it nicely we'll do now is
smoothing out
the gluten strands
push
and tuck in
push and tuck in and each every time you
do this getting softer you just sort of
form
like this perfect
beautiful
dough
it smells delicious that saffron is very
powerful
now
sit that in your bowl cover it with clim
film let it rest for 10 to 15 minutes
this relaxes the dough making it easier
to roll and gives it time to infuse with
the saffron i'll cut that into three and
then roll them nice and thinly now
lightly flour the surface
and then
just
bring that
to like a perfect ball
on the board
once you've got that nice ball your
rolling pin
and just roll it out
now
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and just lightly
flour that on top
a little salt
cooking the flatbread is easy just pop
in a hot dry pan and they're ready in
minutes as it hits the pan it starts the
blister
she's ready
for turning
beautiful get that color on there
now you want it nice and crisp almost
blistering on both sides because it's
nice and thin
it's cooked once browned on both sides
just cool on a rack flatbread's done now
on to the muscles now the secret
behind cooking
great muscles
is in the speed you cook
the key is to chop and prep your
ingredients before you start
cooking first thing pancetta i want it
quite chunky if you can't get pancetta i
always like to use a sort of streaky
bacon
because i want to sort of render all
that flavour
at the streaky bacon
now tomatoes garlic and chili
cherry tomatoes they're just going in
whole
the garlic
just crush the garlic
so all that flavor comes out chilli
i want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked little touch
of olive oil
pancetta in
pancetta takes moments once it's brown
and crisp put your garlic chili and
whole cherry tomatoes into the pan
mussels go in
okay and i'm using dry sherry i think it
works better in this recipe than white
wine which is classically used at this
stage
then oregano finely chopped stalks and
all i'll go
on
and then just give that
a little mix
and we'll see those muscles
start to open lid goes on
you've got to lock in that flavour
gotta lock in
that heat the mussels will take four to
five minutes to steam in the meantime
cut your flatbreads into strips
crispy
and crunchy
now the muscles
wow that is incredible
my goodness me
[Music]
now that is one lunch i definitely don't
want to miss
healthy and delicious
doesn't get any better than that
incredible
steam muscles with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy
[Music]
the great thing about pastry is if you
follow the basic rules the possibilities
are endless whether it's simple short
crust or flaky filo
you just need a bit of practice to get
it right
my first recipe uses lovely buttery
shortcuts pastry to make a dish that's
as delicious as it is simple leaking
pancetta quiche
shortcuts pastry is one of the staples
of the kitchen
it is so versatile but the good news is
it's one of the easiest pastries to make
trust me when you crack it it can make a
real difference to your cooking
take a sieve
when you think of short crust pastry
it's sort of
semi-flaky but it's rich
buttery
start by sipping 200 grams of plain
flour into a mixing bowl
large pinch
of salt
200 grams of unsalted butter
bring the butter up to room temperature
if you let the butter become too soft
then the flour so it doesn't absorb it
in with your fingers rub together first
now the secret is grab big handfuls and
squeeze the butter
into the flour
so look what's happened literally in 30
seconds i've got that nice
crumbly
texture
now a couple of tablespoons
of water nothing worse when the pastry
is so wet you can't bring it together it
needs to shape like a nice rich cookie
dough it's just a touch too dry
so
one more
tablespoon of water
[Music]
and there you go it's coming nicely
now
that's what i want
a nice sort of
firm ball of pastry
onto the board
i'm going to use these
one of the strongest parts of the body
pull towards you
and push back down use
those wrists
to really
knead it
together
so just that nice sort of smooth texture
now
wrap it in cling film
set that in the fridge for 20 minutes
really important that you let the
shortcuts pastry relax
[Music]
now to make the quiche you can use just
an ordinary flan dish but i love making
them in many frying pans which gives
them an extra rustic charm
brush with oil to stop the pastry from
sticking
once the pastry is at room temperature
roll it out to a nice even thickness
place it in the center of your little
pan
turn it in don't use your fingers
because what we don't want is any holes
in this just get a little bit of
dough because that sort of acts like a
little sort of mallet
flattens it out nicely
i'm building a sort of
extra lip because that way i can get the
filling at it's absolute maximum levels
we're going to cook them blind first
to blind bake simply means to pre-cook
your pastry before adding the filling
this ensures you'll have a fantastic
crisp pastry
add a sheet of foil or baking paper and
weigh it down
you can use rice pulses or ceramic
baking stones
just make sure you keep them for the
next time
in the oven 200 degrees for 10 minutes
now for the filling
i'm gonna do a classic quiche bacon and
leeks this is a amazing cured pancetta
pancetta is an italian cured meat made
from belly pork seasoning with things
like juniper nutmeg fennel a great
substitute is unsmoked bacon
as the pancetta gets lovely and crispy
finely slice leeks and add
leeks and bacon nice
really important to cook those leeks
down
that's exactly what i want those leaks
are almost sort of caramelized slightly
crispy the flavor's amazing and just
drain them off so any excess fat gets
drained
a couple of tablespoons of cream
it gives it
a really nice richness
i want two-thirds garnish i.e bacon and
leeks in my quiche and one-third of the
savory custard a touch of salt
a touch of pepper
i'm gonna grate some gruyere cheese
that makes a really nice sort of creamy
less of an eggy quiche take my amazing
crispy pancetta and leeks in
give that a good mix
needs one more little thing some
freshness
flat
leaf
parsley incredible
really important just to taste
the mixture
with the quiche filling ready next
finish off the pastry
[Music]
remove the fall and weight and return to
the oven to get it lovely and golden all
over
[Music]
now
when we fill them give that a really
good mix up
[Music]
beautiful
grate over some more cheese which will
bubble up and melt beautifully and then
into the oven
bake your quiche for 15 to 20 minutes
[Music]
incredible
it's got that nice sort of cheese and
toast smell from the top it's sort of
baked but the secret of any good quiche
is in the short crust because that's the
hero
we're creating bbq style beef brisket
with crunchy coleslaw and sweet potato
wedges which will be right up her street
holly
now
you love barbecues right
so gonna help me barbecue this delicious
piece of brisket brisket
look at it
beautiful it's a very tough cut of meat
so it needs to be cooked slowly so it
gets really nice and tender are we
barbecuing it outside we're gonna
actually put the barbecue flavor on
there but we're gonna cook it in the
oven
okay
so mustard powder
okay here we have some celery seed
next
a little bit of salt in there
okay what's this here cumin two again
nice
good now this one
cayenne pepper absolutely right right
two teaspoons of that in there as well
good
now what i want you to do
fresh pepper on there
i'll give that a little mix
roll up your little sleeves and then
i want you to rub
all that spice
into the brisket
almost like you're massaging it in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there good girl
now that's nice and coated okay
in the spice
so gas on roasting tray on what we've
got to do now with all those spices is
sear them in a couple of tablespoons of
olive oil into the tray
well done good that's getting nice and
hot now you get your brisket
and all that spice
lay that in there nicely
okay so now
we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in
you smell those spices yep all that
spice left on the plate
we're gonna use yeah
i want you to get the onions
nice and carefully
slice them down not too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
smell all those spices now
good girl
thank you don't wash my hands
damn holly
was homework that bad
no the onions oh no don't rub your eyes
don't rub your eyes
[Music]
we've got the colour
look
on the brisket okay yeah
take that out literally for 30 seconds
okay
onions into the tray please
nice
you see it's starting to smell slightly
barbecuey already give that a little
stir
nice
now one nice tablespoon of brown sugar
what does the brown sugar do dad so the
brown sugar you're gonna start
caramelizing the onions
right from there my bay leaves in please
good girl oh yes please
right we'll take over
good care of that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon
of tomato puree roast that off at the
bottom of the tray and really rub it in
amongst the onions good girl
now look at the colors onions
right now time for a little drink
for the brisket
okay one bottle of beer in please so you
go in you put yours in there i'll put
mine here
god uh good health to you and your
brisket
good health
bring that to the ball
okay now this is where it gets really
exciting i want you to lift the brisket
up and put it on top of the onions and
she goes
good girl
and then i want you to pour the stock
all the way around please
i'm using beef stock but it will work
with chicken stock or even vegetable
stock
once the stock has come to the boil
cover tightly with foil you just pinch
in the ends
flat that down and then you just twist
all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
first job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds until beautifully
aromatic
then put them in a pestle and mortar add
salt and grind
[Music]
next smoked paprika dried oregano
cayenne pepper and mix
spice mix done
now simply cut your sweet potatoes into
wedges toss in olive oil and thoroughly
cover with the spice mix
onto a baking tray and into a preheated
oven for 30 minutes turning halfway
irresistible sweet potato wedgies are
ready now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh
now look at that so we can leave that to
rest what does resting mean resting
means where you've cooked a joint and
you just leave it to relax so it'll make
the meat so much more tender okay right
coleslaw traditionally you would mix
slaw with what
mayonnaise that's right mayonnaise this
time we're gonna do it a little
different so i'd like you to put the
yogurt into the bowl for me
please all of it i'll start slicing the
white cabbage
and the red cabbage
now from there a nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up
nice little touch
of salt and pepper
okay
now
a little cider vinegar so a little
splash of cider vinegar
in there okay as i shred this okay i'd
like you please
then to get the
red cabbage and just open up into that
and mix in at the same time and then you
fold that in there as i start shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now for
the white
so
you've got that nice vinegary
tartness to the slaw and the yogurt
keeps it nice and fresh
last little bit in
one more little thing
so
put some nice
chopped
fresh chives in there and that will give
it this nice light
onion flavor
so
shines in
[Music]
how's that
now taste it with the chives in there
delicious so
i would like you
to fill up the bowl i'm gonna very
carefully lift out
my brisket how come is it shrunk
it's been in the oven
for nearly
three and a half hours
so it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
i'll start slicing it and see how soft
look at that
and here's the thing about helping daddy
cook
here's the perk
you get to taste it first
before anybody that is so good
that
tastes
delicious
see all that wonderful flavor in there
last job is to create an incredibly
quick and delicious sauce
gas on and reduce the spicy juices and
onions the beef cooked in
then add in cider vinegar and you've got
a brilliant tangy barbecue sauce
that smells nice doesn't it
wow
that is brisket
and a half now the rest of it
can go in the gravy pot
that's a really nice rich
spicy
barbecue
onion gravy
that my daddy
is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready
if you carry
the sweet potato for me i've got the
brisket wow
let's go donny well done by the way
thank you
this is a real american beauty gorgeous
low and slow cooked barbecue beef
brisket with sweet potato wedges and
yogurt coleslaw
megan jack
tilly big deep smoky flavors that bring
the taste of the american south to your
kitchen
you